i never thought i'd buy a house in japan
older japanese houses are beautiful but
they get way too hot in the summer way
too cold in the winter and they
typically require a ton of renovations
before they're really safe or livable
on the other hand
most modern factory-built japanese
houses are kind of the exact opposite
they're
hyper functional but
they sort of lack the soul and the
warmth of traditional japanese
architecture of an older japanese house
and
there isn't really a third option this
is what i thought at least until
about 14 months ago when my wife
discovered a small local housing company
called scenery house and what we ended
up building together isn't just a house
but it's also an office as well as a
guest room in southern japan that my
other youtube buddies and my twitch
friends can come out you know they can
come out to the place and
visit and relax and make videos of their
own at and um
it's it's really unbelievable
naturally this whole thing is is a big
risk for me it's sort of a big gamble
but when i saw the kind of spaces that
the team at scenery house was making i
felt like i had to step up to the plate
and get out of my comfort zone and go
way above budget such that they could
make something truly special and
i don't regret it for a second because
i'll just let the house speak for itself
i want to say a big thank you to norm
from tokyo lens as well as manu another
one of my youtube buddies who's
launching a new channel that we just
collaborated on i want to thank both of
them for coming out and helping me with
this video and i want to say a big thank
you to
all of you guys for your support over
the years none of this would have been
possible without you guys and
thanks to all of your support
i think we really were able to build
something remarkable something truly
special so
thank you again to all of you i think
that most people want to just see that
see the house though so i'll stop
talking and we can start the house tour
now
so this is
dogen and norm and manu and we've
finally gotten to the inside of my house
they don't know what to expect and now
we're going to start the inside of the
house tour so
okay open your eyes
no
that's lovely
[Music]
so right now we're at the in the
gangplank naturally but
one of the
cool things is that we've got this is
the guest gang gun so this such that you
can kind of go through here and it's
clean and you don't have to see like all
of our dirty shoes and stuff like that
so there's two entrances and then this
is the family
shoe closet
[Music]
it is like you have a secret room
honestly i've always thought if i ever
built a house that i would want like a
secret passageway
you have that kind of yeah we can just
kind of walk in here right now but norm
we're here you're standing right now
there's a little like coat hair rack
right now that's still above the
right yeah the gang gun like doma like
the actual sound floor yeah the stone
floor
and so like on a rainy day you can hang
up your uh your coats here
you probably saw this at the beginning
you were wondering like you know what
this is what the architect did is he
said you've got this larger piece of
land and the reason that it's it's cheap
is because it doesn't have a view but i
still want you to have a nice view of
something because you're surrounded by
houses
let's put in nature in the middle of the
house and they built the house around
this section of the house right here on
the on the right side of the courtyard
this is kind of like the sleeping area
yeah and then this is kind of like the
rest of right living area yeah so maybe
we'll check this out this area first
check it out thank you so
oh
that's so cool
no
it's like a working area kind of yeah so
so cool this area right here this is my
daughter's room
and if you kind of look if you're if
someone points it out to you you'll
notice it immediately but
if you divide the room
like this it's symmetrical completely
symmetrical in the future yeah when when
my daughters want more privacy
we're going to build another wall here
and they're each going to have their own
room
and then these these doors come in from
the sides yeah
[Music]
kind of like clothes here and everyone
has their own door kind of thing exactly
because this room
if you were to split it in two it would
become
two
slightly
semi like
smaller tiny rooms
we tried to move the desks that they
would use for studying out of the room
and into the hallway
there's this giant desk that comes
across
the entire length of the hallway and
naturally they can put up like their
study books and stuff like that in the
future here the kitchen is right across
the way yeah such that you know my wife
can be like hey you know dinner is ready
or whatever yeah she can kind of you
know check up on on them and i can check
up on them as well from the opposite
side of the house little details all
that i think are really cool like the
light source from the back here yeah i'm
glad you noticed that it's called uh
you can only see the light reflecting
off of something else like a passive
kind of elimination yeah exactly exactly
maybe we can go to
yeah my my bedroom now
thank you
[Music]
that's awesome awesome oh oh i thought
it like connected
but it doesn't it doesn't
and you're gonna see why in a second one
of the things that
we decided to go with it was a much more
expensive option
but um i'm hoping that i'll be able to
pay off in the future by making more
videos like this
is um
we have central air conditioning in the
summer
cold air will come
down from above yeah and in the winter
hot air will come up from below
so i think it's also worth mentioning
that
being in japan for about the past
decade and a half this is only the third
home i've ever seen that has central
life yeah yeah not common one of the
things that the architect said is like
the fact that you no longer see these
kind of like big machines
in each like individual room he's like
that'll make a major difference i
totally agree with him though because i
think that's usually
like even if you have a super beautiful
japanese house or like a really
beautiful room the air conditioner is
usually the the one thing that kind of
almost stands out is like the clunky
it's got that tube that goes from it
opens a hole in the wall
yeah yeah
where you're putting your hand right now
there are going to be a
roll screens that come down okay so
another thing that this house doesn't
have is it doesn't have any curtains
maybe we can check out the first four
amazing japanese toilets
it's just a basic you know
well i mean even a basic japanese toilet
is typically quite nice compared to like
back in the states but um
you guys can just kind of check it out
yeah sure i like i like the small little
details with the plant though i guess
that's still from the is that that's the
housing company that may not be there in
the future all the ninja stuff is what
i'm loving ah right
okay so now we're going to go into kind
of the uh
i don't know family kitchen area of the
house what
this is the nicest kitchen i've ever
seen in my entire life literally
yeah
right this is like a tv kitchen you get
to keep this right yes
it's the best question ever now one of
the things that um you might be
wondering perhaps uh subconsciously is
where is like the uh the kitchen hood
like when you're cooking where did the
fumes go
is that
that's it
so um
my wife was pretty adamant about she
cooks a lot i don't do any cooking she
asked the architect like you know
normally kitchen kitchens have like
these these low hoods and i understand
that it's necessary but is there any way
to create that ventilation system
without having this low kitchen house
such that you know
i can i can have a view of the
of the trees and the vegetation but what
they've done is
behind this vent right here
and actually inside
there there's like a high-powered fan
that sucks the area yeah and so all the
air that comes up from here it pushes it
out to the outside of the house fridge
will go here okay
naturally naturally
it's like they they really
you know wow
don't make it any bigger than it needs
to be yeah it's like this is the size of
your fridge okay we're going to work
with that size um so you picked kind of
oh my with all the hidden doors
so this is my uh my
my wife's kitsch or pantry rather
so now i'm going to tell you
probably what's
maybe my favorite thing about the house
and that's
this window not only is
is the frame itself wood but in making
this wood
[Music]
it also means
it also means that like this area here
yeah
there's no like aluminum here it's just
you know
yeah wood and if you
come over to the kitchen again and look
at look out from the kitchen while this
is open now that the uh you know the
pillar in the middle is gone it's like
this big open that's so cool it's almost
like a painting you can open this up
this wide and because the house is built
around you don't have to worry about an
intrusive breeze coming in or anything
like a strong wind or anything you just
get this gentle feeling about i can't
put it into a good word you get the
point also what looks really nice is the
green of the mommyj with like the black
yeah i like a lot do they change colors
well in autumn yes yes that will also
probably look really awesome japan is
extremely hot during the summer
and so there's going to be times when we
want to block out the incoming sunlight
yeah right and
that was a giant window that didn't have
any curtains on it and again there's no
curtain rail up here rather than
curtains for the larger areas of the
house when they want to block out the
sunlight we've got these these built in
[Music]
uh probably good to get it from this
side yeah
ah yeah the sun's coming up in the
morning
it'll be coming up from that side such
that you can kind of just barely make
out the silhouettes of the trees yeah i
got the lobster with you
yeah this was a thing that the designer
like insisted on
or the architect rather he said i
i don't use curtains
yeah and so in place of that we're going
to use this traditional japanese you
know paper doors we're going to use that
instead
all
[Music]
what's even cooler about this one over
here
this is what's known as
zucchini
and
just
the whole purpose of these is like if it
snows during winter
you can kind of you know just get like a
kind of taste
of the outside they have the snow on the
outside over there but like this kind of
for privacy again yeah exactly exactly
you can kind of maintain that scenario
i also like these windows up there just
like flooding
a lot of light here's another uh example
of the uh
you know
or not
and then this is a uh
sofa so
[Music]
it's built in oh nice my wife and i are
both big coffee lovers
and we thought it would be kind of
multi-night
um kind of like what we were talking
about earlier like we don't need a table
if that table's not being used right so
these are you know cup holders
that's so cool
so you know
coffee
put it down over here is this also part
of the ventilation or is that just it is
that's a really good catch
so the the hot air comes from under the
couch and you'll you guys will love this
but
the specific reason that there is a uh a
lan port down here yeah is because i'm a
youtuber and in the future i plan on
doing live streams from different areas
of the house and it's always good to
have a wired connection
and this is a really
great looking part of the house and it
would be great to do interviews on this
couch right here and sometimes you know
live uh live stream though straight to
you know twitch or whatever it's
actually kind of funny you mentioned it
because like this
kind of color scheme also reminds me of
the setup you have for your studio yeah
it kind of yeah yeah yeah with the blue
and everything it's kind of like a
sweater
yeah yeah yeah yeah but now we can come
over here
so before you try try for now to look
over this direction try not to look down
that way just
um and actually you can look
you can look like over here right here
this is clearly you know the area where
the washing machine is going to go the
washing machine is here
and then you
you didn't think about this when we saw
it earlier
but
you're going to realize oh that's true
when i point it out right now right the
girls room in my room didn't have
closets
and the reason for that is because
there's one
there's only one family closet oh wow
[Music]
well there's four people and there are
no other closets in the house this is an
intentional design decision
when the laundry is done
here
you take one step and put it in the
closet rather than walking it all the
way across the house to the other side
i've never really thought about this but
honestly
after taking a shower like before you
know at night or something most of your
changing happens
there in or near the laundry room or
bathroom anyway
exactly if i something i don't actually
get changed in my bedroom almost
ever yeah like how many i've never
thought how many times do you like you
know have like your your underwear like
your t-shirts like you put them on like
the sink next to the bathroom rather
than walking across the house naked
there's another door right here you can
close this and you can use the closet
when you need to use a changing room
kind of yeah exactly exactly is this a
pull-up bar that was i want to drop it
it is this is a pull-up i was insist i
used to be into martial arts tricking i
really like doing pull-ups and working
out but it's
unless you buy one of these equipment
things equipment things that take up
half a room yeah then it's really hard
to do pull-ups in like a modern japanese
house because japanese door frames
aren't built to have those ones exactly
just break it right off i have like
something in my room that i don't think
is meant for it because i think it's
more like a hanger kind of display
exactly
[Music]
of japan and as a result of that
there are many houses in beppu
regardless of whether there are
expensive houses or not that have built
in onsen
and we have an onsen as well i feel like
we're about to get spirited away so here
we go
oh yes
oh my god what
that is
and it has its own private little window
with the garden there oh yes norm
earlier when we were in the bedroom
that sounds so bad
one of the things that you said is oh
your your bedroom doesn't wrap around it
doesn't connect and the reason for that
is because again onsen they have
materials that can corrode yeah there's
waterproofing behind this wall that it
kind of extends all the way around there
right such that even if we're using
onsen it doesn't go into the bedroom
moisture yeah exactly because that's the
second humidity i guess it is it is but
actually
feel free to
come down here and sit down there's a
big cut out you can see it off of the
sky up there oh yes i have like a really
weird obsession with like places like
it's been like nice onsen mm-hmm
with a nice view where you kind of like
relax and kind of like embrace yeah this
is so nice
i got a recommendation for you later
yeah please one of the biggest problems
that i have with showers
globally
is
that the the shower head is always so
small and you you got constantly like
move around and find that position
you don't have that problem here because
this look at this
hmm
[Music]
yeah i'm a cool person a tall person
and if you this this right here
um this is
what would you say standard height
for a japanese
shower and
you have a really nice microphone
yeah
it was a stupid question i said well how
are we going to water those trees in the
architecture just use the shower yeah
yeah so
dogen can i see my room
yes
i'm moving in by the way as a youtuber
that doesn't live in tokyo
both of you do live in tokyo and i want
to make videos with you guys but i can't
fly out to tokyo all the time and you
guys can't come to bed all the time
because hotels are expensive so i really
wanted to have a guest room
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so this
is the guest room nice
and the reason it's here
is because we wanted to make a space
where the guests
could if they wanted to to stay up at
night and work to use like their
speakers on their laptops and not worry
about whether they were going to wake us
up or not so there's another bathroom oh
my god so
so when you guys come oh that's so cool
and you you know want to stay up and
you'll edit a video at night and you
need to use the bathroom there's no way
we would hear anything that's happening
here it's like from that side yeah it's
up and it's across like this big open
area so yeah wow actually yeah yeah
holy that's a big closet you can have a
whole extra guest in there yeah we
wanted at least room
at least room for um
two
in case two people want to come at a
time yeah space or like your your camera
gear your backpacks and stuff like that
and that's what this is for and then
again there's a there's a plug up here
you guys can
yeah charge batteries charge your
cameras etcetera etcetera that's just
been so thought through this is fun for
like the kids like if they're playing up
here they can you know hey daddy yeah or
whatever you know so you play nerf with
them and yeah
take the high ground just pop up
you should build up some mystery for
like the viewers and be like i can't
believe that you guessed the little yeah
and see is that the actual imperial
palace there
this is the shoe closet that we came in
earlier then that's the kitchen area
just for kind of frame of reference
um
and then this is kind of just some
additional storage
oh that space there's already so cool
we're getting antsy now this is gonna
already be pretty fun as an
officer yes one of the things that the
architect said that i thought was so
interesting is you work from home but
the thing about working from home we've
talked about this a lot is that when you
work where you live slash sleep it's
very hard to distinguish between working
mode
and relaxation and or non-working mode i
appreciate that so much yeah yeah like
we talked about this i struggle with
that because i'm still shooting most of
my stuff from my bedroom exactly which
it's hard it sucks too yeah it's like
when do i say it's time to go to bed and
chill and yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
okay i just stopped working but i'm
sitting in the same chair now just
watching netflix yeah am i working or am
i
and it's like as a dad you gotta decide
it's like no i need like family time
yeah let's go into the uh office now
oh yeah
[Music]
oh my god
it looks so much better than you
described oh you suck at describing
things
amazing when we were uh
in the very initial stages he
said you're currently working from home
in your own office what's like the
number one thing that's most difficult
if you could change what would you do
and i said you can both appreciate this
for sure that when you film in your room
your room starts to become a forest of
tripods yes i asked him i said do you
think there's any way that we can
set up a lighting system such that i can
get enough light and like enough
flexibility to change things when i when
i need to
and
not need to put in
this giant
light tripod that's currently in my
office
and he said i'll see what i can do
and um
what he ended up doing is what you see
up here there's these light rails that
go across the ceiling most of the time
these aren't even going to be on yeah
and it's going to be instead
these sidelines it just looks so good
even just this the reason that the
ceiling is like this
as opposed to just completely flat is
and i don't know if how much this is
actually working but apparently
like a box
a box room echoes a lot more
oh you're giving a lot less echo because
of this if you don't mind yeah yeah if
you go like this
versus going like this you can tell oh
yeah that's interesting like this
like
yeah versus
yeah and then behind
here this is where my my desk is going
to go
is that the nest uh
yeah so this is the standing desk and
it's currently in a position where it
would hit this
but um
i'm gonna obviously move it a little bit
more forward the architect uh he said
everywhere there's a map there's a
window there's got to be some green as
well yeah yeah yeah yeah so like this is
also i open that up and i see that yeah
kind of like and then my uh the pantry
is right over there yeah yeah so
like honestly it makes the it makes the
pantry and kitchen area like command
central
you know what i mean if you are there
you can direct everyone in the house
kids come up yeah
let's go you know what i mean yeah yeah
yeah this is just such a great space to
be able to call your own
okay you're getting our reaction
everything but yeah how do you like you
how do you feel about it i am pleased
beyond words i'm trying to make this
house
as much a cool space for people like you
and my other friends you know our other
buddies chris joey connor etc etc
a place that they can come and feel
welcome and we can you know chill and
make videos together it's it's more than
just
dogan's house i felt so privileged to
work with this architect and it's like
if i'm presented with this opportunity
then i want to try and push myself
beyond my limits
and you know
make something that's even out of my own
reach i feel like just as a creator
standing here like you kind of want to
create something yeah exactly so yeah
yeah like as we've been going through
i'm like oh i can shoot this here i can
shoot that there yeah i'm a big fan of
japanese traditional we talked about
this a lot like traditional japanese
architecture but it has a lot of
drawbacks but then you combine it with
like a lot of modern elements i've done
it here
yeah yeah like um when it comes shines
the most almost i feel yeah it is kind
of like what would you say japanese art
architecture 2.0 right yeah this is sad
that you can't capture it in video but
like i would like i don't know smell and
yeah touch just me yeah i keep dogging
keeps getting mad at me because i keep
touching them
so maybe we can head back over to the uh
yes
and maybe we can just like chill out
there first absolutely older japanese
houses and like temples they have this
thing called an engage which is which is
essentially what we're on right now it's
like this long kind of
porch thing right that goes right along
the windows oftentimes like uh
you know it'd be like the granny that
has like tea out here or whatever
you know we plan on putting like a like
a little
table out here like just a small little
you know deck set
there's nothing else to say and then
congrats man wow thank you
congratulations on this place
yeah
wow
i love the very peaceful yeah it's like
it's almost like comically
like tranquil here
[Music]
[Music]
so that's the place guys and again i
couldn't be happier with how it turned
out i'm completely blown away of course
we've got a couple more videos in the
pipeline related to the house but i
imagine some of you may have questions
about sort of like the building process
the materials the cost of everything or
just parts and you know etc etc so feel
free to leave those questions down below
and i'll try and answer all of those in
a separate video and i would also
say please check out norm and molina's
videos on the house as well they're both
way better at making this kind of
content than me they're just both
incredible creators so i would encourage
everyone to check out their channels and
their videos that are linked down below
thank you again to all of you guys for
your continued support and i'll see you
again soon
[Music]
you